tonight the ACM honors hair on CBS and
you know fashion is usually a really big
part of these award shows what are those
two guys not so much well tell me about
your pre-show ritual we saw each other
in our underwear because we were we were
changing together to get our outfit
picked out Luke and Kol did pull their
outfits together in time but for
first-time hosts Lady Antebellum having
Luke in their audience might have thrown
their Gabe off a bit thus are hosting
debuts so please don't please don't
judge us if we mess up yeah I know but
you have like Dierks Bentley and Luke
Bryan are in the front row and I'm a
little like gonna tell him beforehand
like don't judge of course
Luke and Dirks hosted the ACM Awards
last April this time it was Dirk singing
his hit freedom she's gone from being
something that was kind of like a
national insiders kind of thing with no
TV and now it's like this great moment
we got to share for the fans Miranda
Lambert was honored with the Spirit
Award noticeably not onstage at the same
time was her ex Blake Shelton
Lake st. Glen Campbell's southern
Knights and then joined an all-star team
including Keith Urban's saluting the
country great who is now suffering from
Alzheimer's
it was awesome getting to sing no songs
of those guys yeah I mean and there are
amazing songs